Oh, Miss, I got a question.
Are you ready?
(Cheering)
Wow,
that was impressive.
They told me that would be impressive and
they were exactly right.
So let me say, let me say a few words of
thank you first to my dear friend and the
widow of my dear friend Charlie Kirk.
Erica, you have been such an amazing
inspiration to the entire country.
How much do we love?
Erica Kirk.
She's done a hell of a job.
I want to thank, we have a couple of
Mississippi senators here.
We have both Senator Roger Wicker and
Senator Cindy Hyde-Smith.
Thank you guys for being here.
We have the governor
of Mississippi with us.
We got an all-star crowd here.
Governor, thank you for being here.
And most importantly, we have got over
10,000 students from across Mississippi.
We are proud to have you and we know that
you are the future of
Charlie Kirk's legacy.
So thank you for being here.
I got this whole speech written and I'm
not going to deliver
any of what I had written.
I'm just going to speak from the heart
because that's what
Charlie would so often do.
You know, when I think about what we lost
six weeks ago, it feels like forever ago
when I was in a meeting in the West Wing
and one of my staff members came in and
said that Charlie had been shot.
And then I looked at my phone and I saw
all the text messages and realized that
my dear friend had been
very seriously injured.
Now, in the West Wing at that time, we
actually thought that
Charlie had a chance.
We didn't know that he was
eventually going to pass away.
There were initial reports from the
medical team that maybe
things were going okay.
And of course, eventually Charlie took
his last breath and went home to be with
his Lord and Savior.
I remember thinking at that moment,
first, of course, about
Erica and the children.
They've got their oldest, their daughter
is very similar in age
to our youngest child.
And I remember thinking, what a terrible
tragedy for that family.
And the second thing that I thought was
what a terrible tragedy for the United
States of America because Charlie wasn't
just a political figure.
He wasn't just a guy who went around
campus and said very interesting things
and hosted all of these debates.
He was a person who particularly to the
young people of this country, to all of
you, he had the very best advice.
And I think that's the most important way
for me to honor Charlie, which is to
repeat that advice, something I found
true in my own life.
Charlie wanted all of you, whatever life
path he chose, whatever career you chose,
whatever you ultimately did for a living.
Charlie wanted you more than anything to
invest in the things that were worth
having to build a life
that was worth building.
And that started the most important
advice he ever gave you was fall in love,
get married and start a family.
And I can't honor Charlie without
repeating that most important advice.
Now, now most of you are probably too
young to have found the person you're
going to spend the
rest of your life with.
Some of you are lucky enough to have
found that person already.
But I will tell you, if you're as lucky
and blessed as I have been, it hits you
like a ton of bricks.
And I found that person and my lovely
wife, Usha, our second lady
who is here with us today.
She's sitting in the audience somewhere.
I don't know where.
But I love you, honey.
And have children.
That's something
Charlie also always told.
I grew up in a generation.
I'm 41 years old.
I'm a millennial.
And if you're being uncharitable, you
would call me a geriatric millennial,
which I really hate.
I really hate being
called a geriatric millennial.
But here I am at 41 talking to all of you
like I've got great wisdom.
Here's the thing.
The one regret, the only regret that I
really have in my entire life and I've
made plenty of mistakes.
But the one regret that I have is that,
frankly, I wish we had
started having kids sooner.
Because when you're a young father, you
realize what an
incredible blessing they are.
But they're also very exhausting.
And I know here at Ole
Miss, we like to party a lot.
And I know at Ole Miss, occasionally some
of you will have a few drinks on a Friday
or Saturday or
hopefully not a Tuesday night.
But I'm sure that happens from time to
time here in SEC country.
But here's the thing.
When you go out until 3 in the morning
and wake up at 6 a.m. for class, the
thing that I've learned in my old age is
that incredible energy.
God actually meant it
for another purpose.
And that purpose was to
help take care of a family.
So while you're young, have
those babies if you're able to.
That's something
Charlie said all the time.
But if you think of that advice, if you
think of that advice,
Charlie wanted you to get married.
He wanted you to fall in love.
He wanted you to build a family.
He wanted you to find a vocation.
That was the advice
that he gave on campuses.
But that's not just about you.
That's also about our
country and about our government.
Because while you have the freedom to
live life as you so choose, I have got a
responsibility as your Vice President to
make the American dream
as accessible as possible.
And this is why, my friends, this is why
we care about all the
things that we care about.
Why do I care so much about having a
secure border in the
United States of America?
It's because I believe that when you let
in a flood of illegal immigration, what
it does is it drives down the wages of
young people and makes housing
unaffordable for the
entire American population.
That's why we closed down the border.
(Applause)
The left will say our immigration policy
is about hating
immigration, hating immigrants.
We don't hate anybody.
We love our fellow citizens.
And because we want them to have the
American dream, we shut that border down
the very first day that Donald J.
Trump was the
President of the United States.
(Applause)
I care about you being able to afford a
home, which is why we fought so hard to
fix the broken policies of
the Biden administration.
I want a lot of you, I'm sure there are
military veterans in this room right now.
I'm sure there are a lot of people who
will join the military in the
future and we're proud of you.
But part of America First is ensuring
that we never ask you to go and do the
American people's business unless it is
in the interest of the
United States of America.
And that's how we honor
the sacrifice of our troops.
(Applause)
And that's why, my friends, that's why we
care so much about free speech.
As Charlie lived and died for the basic
principle that we ought to be able to
talk about our differences, we ought to
be able to debate them, and we ought to
have faith that the best way to make sure
that the best idea wins is to actually
just have a discussion.
And that is what this event is all about.
That is what Turning
Point's USA is all about.
And I am so proud, and most of all, I'm
so grateful to each and every person,
whether you're a Republican or a
Democrat, for coming out and honoring one
of the most important parts of Charlie's
legacy, because we're going
to have a discussion tonight.
And that's what
Charlie would want us to do.
(Applause)
Now, I want to get to questions, and I
want to leave plenty of time for
questions, but I want to make just a
couple of final points about Charlie's
legacy and politics.
The most important thing about Charlie is
that he was a great
husband and a great father.
Erica told me, probably 12 hours after
Charlie had been pronounced dead, she was
just absolutely
devastated, she was unable.
You know, if you've ever known anybody
who's grieving, sometimes it's unable,
they're unable to even hold a single
thought for more than a few seconds.
And what Erica told me, and I'm going to
get a little emotional, is that she said
that Charlie never yelled at her, he
never cussed at her, and that to me is a
great legacy to leave as a husband and a
father for your wife to be able to say
that my husband was always good to me,
and Charlie was a good man.
(Applause)
But he also, but he also had the legacy
of believing in political debate, and he
was the most effective person in politics
that I have ever seen.
And by the way, that's not because
Charlie always agreed with me in the
President's policies.
I remember one time in particular where
Charlie Kirk called me
and guys, he was mad.
It was one, you know, I wouldn't say the
last conversation that I had with him,
but it was in the last few months of his
life, and he called me and he
said, "JD, I'm really worried.
I'm really worried that what's going on
in the Middle East right now is going to
lead the United States into a
protracted military conflict."
I've never told anybody that, that
Charlie was really worried about that in
the final months of his life.
Now here's the thing, Charlie was so
effective, and he was so trusted by both
me and the President of the United
States, that when Charlie made that phone
call, I didn't say, "Screw you, you don't
know what you talk about."
You're talking about, I listened to him.
And I really believe that one of the
reasons why the President of the United
States knocked out the Iranian nuclear
facilities, but never got the United
States into a protracted military
conflict, and never lost a single
American in a Middle Eastern conflict, is
because we had the wisdom and the good
sense to recognize that the American
people are done with American troops
dying in unnecessary foreign conflict.
But Charlie Kirk reminded me of that.
Charlie Kirk.
So that was a great
moment for our country.
It was a great moment for my friendship
with Charlie Kirk, because friendship is
not just about telling
everybody what they want to hear.
It's not just about agreeing with
everybody all the time.
It's about having the trust in another
human being that you can tell them
they're wrong and actually encourage them
to change their mind.
Or in that case, not necessarily even
tell us that we were wrong, but make sure
that we were thinking
about all the options.
And of course, under the President's
leadership, we were doing exactly that,
but Charlie was so good at that.
And I think that's one of the ways in
which I want all of
you to honor your legacy.
Obviously, you care about a great nation
or you wouldn't be here.
A lot of you will go on to become future
leaders in business or in politics.
A lot of you will run campaigns.
A lot of you will work on campaigns.
A lot of you will be future leaders.
There might even be a lowly future Vice
President of the United
States in this very room.
But here's the thing that I
want all of you to remember.
Charlie wasn't effective
just because he had opinions.
A lot of people have opinions.
Charlie was effective because he was
courageous, because he worked very hard,
and because he made his vision a reality.
And so if you care about this country, as
I know all of you do, don't
just complain about social media.
Get up and get involved in a campaign.
If you want a better policy outcome, even
from an administration that you voted
for, then get out and get involved in
making your voice heard.
If you care about this country, love it
enough to get involved in the
process and how we govern it.
That is the only way we are going to save
the United States of America.
And that is perhaps the greatest
contribution that you can make to Charlie
Kirk's legacy is getting involved in
saving this country.
I'm in the fight and I know every single
one of you are with me.
God bless you and
thank you for having me.
Thank you, thank you.
Hey,
please,
I appreciate that, but
we're not even halfway done.
So here's,
I don't know what you're
saying, but it sounds awesome.
Let's
not get ahead of
ourselves, ladies and gentlemen.
What we're going to do next is actually
take some questions.
And I remember one of my favorite things
about Charlie, not that there aren't
going to be some
questioners who agree with me.
But if you disagree with me, I would ask
that you come to the front of the line
because we want to talk
to people we agree with.
We also want to hear from
people we disagree with.
It is hard for me to see because the
spotlight are very bright.
But whoever's in line, go
ahead and ask your question.
Oh, there we go.
Okay, now I can see you.
How are you doing?
Hi, Mr.
Vice President.
Thank you so much for being here.
My name is Lucy and I'm Ellie and we're
with the turning point
chapter for this question.
Thank you, guys.
Yes.
Can you tell us how your faith helps you
in your role as vice president?
Well, I appreciate that.
That is a very good question.
And this is another way in which Charlie
has affected my life.
I would say that I grew up again in a
generation where even if people had very
deep personal faith, they didn't talk
about their faith a whole lot.
And I grew up in a country where you just
didn't hear political
leaders talk about their faith.
But the reason why I try to be the best
husband I can be, the best father I can
be, the reason why I care so much about
all the issues that we're going to talk
about is because I believe that I've been
placed in this position for a brief
period of time to do the most amount of
good for God and for the
country that I love so much.
And that's the most important way that my
faith influences me is we all get a
limited opportunity to make a difference.
And if you believe as we believe, you
believe that God, you believe
that Jesus Christ has a plan.
And sometimes we don't
understand that plan.
By the way, one way I don't understand
that plan is why my friend
lost his life six weeks ago.
Sometimes I get pissed off about that.
But what I remind myself is that there is
a deeper rhythm that Jesus Christ is the
author of the fate of human history.
And we are charged to do everything that
we can to effectuate that vision, to make
our country a more virtuous place, a more
prosperous place where people can raise a
family and not be persecuted for their
faith, but teach their
children their faith.
That recognition that
all of us have a duty.
And I have two very important duties as
vice president of the United States to
the American people and to God.
And that's the most important
influence my faith has on me.
Thank you.
I understand your view on illegal
immigration is it should be a top
priority, strengthening our southern
borders and fighting the massive drug
trafficking that's taken place while
securing jobs for the
working class Americans.
Also, deporting every single person who's
invaded our country
illegally, which I 100% agree on.
My question to you is what is your view
on legal immigration?
Personally, I have a girlfriend who's
studying in America off a visa.
Our hope is eventually
getting a green card.
So what is your view
on legal immigration?
Should we reduce it?
Also, what is your plan
for a merit based system?
Yes, sir.
Well, I appreciate the question.
And look, my honest view is that right
now, America, thanks in part to the Biden
border invasion, but also thanks in part
to a lot of bad immigration policy.
Right now, we have let in too many
immigrants into the
United States of America.
That is just a fundamental reality now.
Now, look, legal immigration is
complicated because we let in about a
million legal immigrants into the United
States of America every single year.
And I think the evidence is pretty clear
that a lot of those immigrants are
actually undercutting the
wages of American workers.
It's one of the reasons why the president
of the United States is one of the
reasons why the president United States
and a lot of us in the administration
have encouraged H-1B reform because if
you look at the H-1B visa, what it's
supposed to be, what it's supposed to be
is that you have a super genius who's
studying at an American university, who's
working at a great company.
You want that super genius to stay in the
United States of America
and not go somewhere else.
What it's actually used to do is hire an
accountant at a 50%
discount to an American citizen.
I don't think that we should be hiring
accountants from foreign countries when
we've got accountants right here in the
United States that would
love to work for a good wage.
Now, you asked about, I think, your
girlfriend, you said, and I obviously
don't know the full details about your
situation, but my view is, look, there
are people who want to come to the United
States of America, and some of them, I'm
sure, can enrich the United States of
America by coming here.
But we have got to get our overall
numbers way, way down.
Too many people have come into
the United States of America.
I am married to the daughter of
immigrants who came to the
United States in the 1980s.
I do believe that some immigrants, many
immigrants do, in fact, enrich
the United States of America.
But here's the problem.
We have got, we don't even know how many
illegal aliens we have.
We don't even know.
The best guess is
probably 25, 30 million people.
I've heard estimates
as high as 50 million.
When something like that happens, you've
got to allow your own society to cohere a
little bit, to build a sense of common
identity for all the newcomers to
assimilate, the ones who are going to
stay, to assimilate
into American culture.
Until you do that, you've got to be
careful about any
additional immigration in my view.
Thank you.
Hello.
I have a question about Israel and
Trump's policy towards it.
Do you think it's a conflict of interest
for Miriam Adelson, an Israeli donor, to
give millions of dollars to his campaign,
and then Trump have pro-Israeli policies?
Well, if you're asking, do I think the
President of the United States has a
conflict of interest?
No, I do not, because I know how the
President of the United States makes his
decisions, and I see
it behind the scenes.
Now, as the President himself has said,
Miriam Adelson, who, by the way, I know,
and I have a very good relationship with
her, she is very clear about the fact.
She doesn't hide the fact that she really
loves Israel, and that is part of what
motivates her political giving.
That is a reality.
At the same time, the President of the
United States is America
first through and through.
And let me give you just a
couple of examples of this.
Number one, we have heard from some
pro-Israel voices, some people who really
love the state of Israel, that they don't
want us to have a relationship with
certain Middle Eastern countries.
Well, the President's attitude is, we
need to build relationships with any
country where we have shared interests,
and he's going to do it if it's in the
interests of the American people, and
he's done exactly that.
Number two, there were people, and I
remember this criticism of the President
of the United States, I just raised it in
the context of a
conversation I had with Charlie.
I remember when people said that the
President of the United States was going
to get us into a multi-hundred thousand
troop regime change war for Israel, this
was four months ago,
this was six months ago.
Now the people who accused the President
of the United States of wanting to get us
into a regime change war for Israel, I
wonder if they stepped back and said, you
know what, we were wrong about that.
Because the President of the United
States did not want to get us into a
regime change war for any other country,
he wanted to knock out a nuclear facility
and get everybody back home, and that's
exactly what he did.
So I understand there's some frustrations
out there, but I think the President of
the United States, more than any
President of my lifetime, is willing to
stand up to anybody if he thinks it puts
the interests of the
American people first.
Thank you.
Hello Vice President Vance.
Good.
I have a question.
Do you condone large private corporations
such as Palantir hoarding
data caches on US citizens?
No, I don't condone it.
And here's the thing.
So I get asked about Palantir a lot
because there's this internet meme out
there that somehow I am
super in bed with Palantir.
And here's the thing
that I'd say about this.
Palantir is a private company.
They sometimes do a useful service and
sometimes they're going to
do things that we don't like.
You should be demanding that your
representatives do two things when it
comes to Palantir or when it comes to any
other technology company.
Number one, protecting your data.
What's going on with artificial
intelligence is going to mean that there
are massive inducements to seal your
data, to harvest it, and to use it
against you to sell
digital advertisements.
That is not what I believe in and I've
been fighting against it whether it's
Palantir or any other technology company
literally before I ran for office.
When I ran for office, I was criticized
by Republicans in my Republican Senate
primary because I was talking then about
Google and Facebook harvesting our data.
It's unacceptable. I don't care who does it,
I don't want them to do it.
Number two, and this is also very
important, what's going on with
artificial intelligence, we got to be
worried about large scale surveillance.
You asked about Palantir, do you know
that every time you make a credit card
transaction, the credit card companies
are collecting data on
how you spend your money?
Do you know that every time you linger
over a link on the internet for more than
a half second, the search engines are
collecting data on you so that they can
sell you advertisements?
One of the biggest questions for American
policy over the next ten years is how to
ensure that you are a sovereign citizen
and you cannot be a sovereign citizen if
any private corporation or any government
can steal something from
you that belongs to you.
Thank you.
Vice
President J.D.
Vance, good evening.
My question is, the Republican Party,
they stand for the right to bear arms, a
lot of things the founding
fathers really made a priority.
And I feel as if requiring Christianity
in public schools goes against the
founding fathers wish
of freedom of religion.
What do you think about that?
Well I guess,
who is saying that we require
Christianity in public schools?
Just from what I've seen on the media and
the news, it seems like the Trump
administration had wanted to make praying
in schools and
Christian values incorporated.
Well look, I think Christian values are a
good thing and I'll talk to you about why
I think that's a good thing, but that's
separate from forcing people to pray,
which I don't think that anybody,
certainly no Christian that I know would
ever support or ever endorse.
Let me just say something
generally about all the people.
I see there's a big line and I hope I can
get to everybody's question.
I remember when I was a sophomore in high
school, I went to an event at my church
which was a book signing with Oliver
North and Sean
Hannity, the Fox News host.
And this was back before, I mean, this
was I guess 25 years ago and so neither
of these guys was maybe
as big as they are today.
And I remember standing in line and I'm
about to say hello to Oliver North and
Sean Hannity and I remember thinking to
myself, I was so nervous.
All I need to do is shake my hand or
shake their hand, give them a firm
handshake and tell them my name.
That's what I'm thinking, firm handshake,
tell them my name, firm
handshake, tell them my name.
And I get to the front of the line and
Sean Hannity looks at me and he says,
"How are you doing?"
And I totally panic and I go, "Uh, JD."
Because I had rehearsed,
shaken and saying my name.
My point is, I admire your guys' courage
and please don't be nervous if you need
to work through a
question, think about it, speak it.
We're all here to have a nice
conversation and we're
all supportive of it.
Here's the thing when you talk about
forcing, let me answer your question,
forcing Christianity,
forcing people to pray.
There's a real, there's a liberal idea
out there that I think is wrong and
that's that liberalism is the source of
freedom of religion.
Actually, if you go back to the original
founding documents of the United States
of America, if you go back to the Anglo
legal tradition well before there was
ever a United States of America, what you
find is that freedom of religion is
actually a Christian concept.
And the reason, and the reason it's a
Christian concept is very simple because
Christianity, Imago Dei, the idea that we
are all made in the image of our creator
means that we must respect the free will
of every single person.
Now part of that is you have a
conversation with people.
Having free will doesn't mean that you're
not allowed to encourage somebody, that
you're not allowed to talk to somebody
about your faith, that you're not allowed
to talk about certain values in school.
When our founders talked about freedom of
religion, they didn't mean you weren't
allowed to say a Christian prayer in a
public school or that you weren't allowed
to talk about Jesus
Christ in a public forum.
They just meant that nobody could force
you to profess the Christian faith that
had to come from your own free will.
And I believe that and I think every
Christian who I've ever spoken to
believes that the source is the
Christian, the source of your faith, the
Christian understanding
must be your own free will.
But here's the thing
about Christian values.
There are a lot of Christian values out
there that I think that we've just sort
of assumed and we've in
fact taken for granted.
Christian values are the idea that you
should respect every
single person as an individual.
Whatever the color of their skin created
in the image of God,
that's a Christian concept.
And in fact, it was a Christian empire,
Great Britain, that
abolished slavery to begin with.
The idea that we should
eliminate child sacrifice.
What did the Christian settlers find when
they came to the new world?
They found a lot of civilizations that
were murdering babies in
weird religious rituals.
It was Christianity that said we don't
kill children just because they're
somehow inconvenient to people.
A lot of the things, human rights, the
very idea that human beings have rights
are a Christian concept.
And so I'd ask you, my assumption based
on the question is that you're skeptical
of Christianity or at least of certain
public professions of Christianity.
One of my favorite Bible verses is "By
your fruits ye shall know them."
And I think that the fruits of the
Christian faith are the most moral, the
most just, and the most prosperous
civilization in history.
I make no apologies for believing that
Christianity is the pathway to God.
I make no apologies for thinking that
Christian values are an important
foundation of this country.
But I'm not going to force you to believe
in anything because that's not what God
wants and that's not what I want either.
So, go ahead.
The school system, do you agree that
there should be Christian implementation
or do you think that school system should
be neutral and be focused on science,
literature, reading, writing, arithmetic?
Well, I reject the idea that anything is
purely neutral, okay?
There are, for example, let's say, let's
take a basic scientific
fact, and this is a little spicy.
I'm not trying to make this too
controversial, but take the basic
scientific fact of can you take a pill to
change your biological gender, okay?
Now, that's something that 15 years ago,
quite literally every single scientist in
the Western world would have said,
"Absolutely not, that's
crazy, and now people will."
I actually, I think the premise of your
question, I don't totally share it
because I don't think
perfect neutrality is possible.
What is it, you talk about history.
Was Christopher Columbus a great explorer
or was he a guy who committed genocide
against the native populations?
These debates, I'm happy to have them,
but I reject the idea that there are
truly neutral debates.
Anybody who's telling you their view is
neutral likely has an agenda to sell you,
and I'm at least honest about the fact
that I think the Christian foundation of
this country is a good thing.
Next.
For the Osterone, estrogen.
Yeah, I'm talking about hormone
replacement therapy,
that's what I'm talking about.
Just to be
respectful, let's keep it going.
Yes, thank you.
Have a good night.
You too.
Hello, Mr.
Vice President.
Thank you so much for giving this
opportunity to talk here today.
I did not agree with many of the things
that you said right ahead of this, but I
don't think that's my
point to discuss here.
What I want to ask is, you are married to
a woman who is not Christian.
In her Wikipedia, I mean, I just looked
that up, I wanted to
know what her faith was.
I didn't know this before, but she still
calls herself Hindu.
You are raising two kids, three kids, in
inter-cultural,
racial, religious household.
How are you maintaining,
or how are you teaching your kids not to
keep your religion ahead of their
mother's religion, or how are you
teaching them that your kind, they're
that kind who got here just a few years
or a few decades ago, is different or is
better than your mom's kind who got here
just a generation before.
How are you balancing that?
And when you talk about too many
immigrants here, when did
you guys decide that number?
Why did you sell us a dream?
You made us spend our youth, our wealth
in this country and gave us a dream.
You don't owe us anything.
We have worked hard for it.
Then how can you as a vice president
stand there and say that we have too many
of them now and we are going to take them
out to people who are here rightfully so
by paying the money
that you guys asked us.
You gave us the path and now, how can you
stop it and tell us we
don't belong here anymore?
And one more thing, I'm
sorry, one more thing.
Do you have to be...
There's a lot there.
I don't know if I'm going to remember all
this, but I will try.
I'm sorry.
I had to say all of this
and please take it with due...
I mean, I'm saying all of this
with due respect.
I have no intention of
causing a scene here or anything.
We're not close to
causing a scene, don't worry.
But we talked about
Christianity, all of this.
I'm not even Christian and I'm here
standing to so support.
Why are we making Christianity one of the
major things that you have to do?
You have to have in common to be one of
you guys to so that I
love America just as you do.
Why is that still a question?
Why do I have to be a Christian?
Okay.
So there was a lot there and I'm going to
try to respond to as much of it as I can.
So on the question of immigration.
So first of all, I can believe that we
should have lower immigration levels.
But if the United States passed a law and
made a promise to somebody, the United
States of course has
to honor that promise.
Nobody's talking about that.
I'm talking about people who came in in
violation of the laws of
the United States of America.
And I'm talking about in the future,
reducing the number.
Reducing the number of people.
Sorry, what?
I continue on that because when you just
said you are not stopping with the people
who came here legally, right?
But you are pushing out
policies that hurt us.
And these policies are not
even solving the problems.
These policies are just creating chaos.
Okay.
So again, I'm going to
finish answering the question.
And then if I've answered all nine of
your questions in less than 15 minutes,
then we can keep on going.
We got to have a little fun, right?
So here's the thing.
I can believe that the United States
should lower its levels of immigration in
the future while also respecting that
there are people who
have come here to help.
And I'm talking about people who have
come here through immigration path,
lawful immigration pathways that have
contributed to the country.
But just because one person or 10 people
or 100 people came in legally and
contributed to the United States of
America, does that mean that we're
thereby committed to let in a million or
10 million or 100 million
people a year in the future?
No, that's not right.
We cannot have, but I'll go and finish,
we cannot have an immigration policy
where what was good for the country 50 or
60 years ago binds the
country inevitably for the future.
There's too many people who want to come
to the United States of America.
And my job as vice president is not to
look out for the
interest of the whole world.
It's to look out for the
people of the United States.
Now, you asked a personal question about
our interfaith household.
And yes, my wife did
not grow up Christian.
I think it's fair to say that she grew up
in a Hindu family, but not a particularly
religious family in either direction.
In fact, when I met my wife, we were
both, I would consider
myself an agnostic or an atheist.
And that's what I think she would have
considered herself as well.
You know, everybody has to come to their
own arrangement here.
The way that we've come to our
arrangement is she's my best friend.
We talked to each other about this stuff.
So we decided to raise our kids
Christian, our two
oldest kids who go to school.
They go to a Christian school.
Our eight year old did his first
communion about a year ago.
That's the way that we
have come to our arrangement.
But thank you.
My eight year old was also very proud of
his first communion.
Thank you guys.
I'll tell him that Ole
Miss wishes him the best.
But I think everybody has to have this
own conversation when
you're in a marriage.
I mean, it's true for friends of mine who
are in Protestant and Catholic marriages,
friends of mine who are in, you know,
atheist and Christian marriages.
You just got to talk to the only advice I
can give is you just got to talk to the
person that God has put you in.
You've got to make those
decisions as a family unit for us.
It works out.
Now, most Sundays, Usha will come with me
to church as I've told her and I've said
publicly and I'll say now in front of
10,000 of my closest friends.
Do I hope eventually that she is somehow
moved by the same thing
that I was moved in by church?
Yeah, I honestly, I do wish that because
I believe in the Christian gospel and I
hope eventually my wife
comes to see it the same way.
But if she doesn't, then God says every
single day, everybody has free will.
And so that doesn't
cause a problem for me.
That's something you work out with your
friends, with your family, with the
person that you love.
Again, the most one of the most important
Christian principles is
that you respect free will.
Usha is closer to the priest
who baptized me than maybe I am.
They talk about this stuff.
My attitude is you figure this stuff out
as a family and you trust in God to have
a plan and you try to
follow it as best as you can.
And that's what I try to do.
I want to make a final point.
So I don't want to cut you off.
I want to be respectful to all the people
behind you in line, but I want to make
this point about immigration.
Okay.
If you ask the question, what is the
exact right number of immigrants for the
United States to let in?
It is just very specific on the context.
If you go back to the 1920s, the United
States passed an immigration reform act
that effectively cut down immigration to
close to zero for 40
years in this country.
And what happened over those 40 years?
The many, many people who had come from
many different foreign countries and
different foreign cultures, they
assimilated into American culture.
And there was an expectation that they
would assimilate into American culture.
I think we have two problems in our
immigration system today.
And my guess is you're probably a
slightly more leftist political
persuasion, liberal political persuasion.
Maybe not.
But here's the thing.
I remember back in my establishment GOP
days when I was still very early getting
involved in Republican
politics, I was in the Senate.
I remember a conservative think tank
person who told me that one of the
reasons why immigration was really good
is that if you had enough diversity in a
country, people would mistrust each other
and they wouldn't join labor unions.
Okay.
So when I see a lot of left wing people
who theoretically support organized labor
saying we need to flood the country with
a limitless number of immigrants, they're
unwilling to set any limitations on it.
My response to that is that you were
destroying the very social trust on which
American freedom and
prosperity was built.
And that is really important.
So the honest answer to your question,
what is the exact number of immigrants
America should accept in the future?
Right now, the answer is far less than
we've been accepting.
We've got to become a
common community again.
And you can't do that when you have such
high numbers of immigration, which is one
of the reasons why we have the
immigration policy we do.
Thank you. Next.
Good evening, Vice President Vance.
I just want to say it's an honor to
actually be able to talk to you.
It's an honor to be here.
Thank you.
Um, one of my biggest questions is I feel
like one of the biggest problems that
America is facing today is that ever
growing social political divide.
And we're seeing this on the Republican
and Democratic side.
But, uh, we've seen that a refusal to
cooperate with the other side has led to
some major issues, including right now
the government shutdown.
And I wonder, um, as the party in power,
what are your plans to address that issue
towards, you know, reaching that all of
branch out to the other side to actually
come to an agreement on how to go forward
with our government?
Look, it's a very good question.
And let me just say on the government
shutdown in particular, the reality here
is that there's a very simple bill that
just reopens the government.
It does it through pretty
much the end of the year.
That got every single Republican in the
House of Representatives to support it.
And then it got 52 Republicans in the
Senate and three Democrats
in the Senate to support it.
But because of weird Senate procedural
rules, it requires a 60 vote threshold.
So on that issue in particular, when you
have every single Republican, with like
two exceptions in both houses of
Congress, I feel pretty confident.
I know that I'm partisan.
I know I have an R next to my name, but I
feel pretty damn good saying the shutdown
is the Democrats fault because we voted
again and again to open.
Now on, but there's a broader question
there, and I think most Americans,
whatever their political persuasion would
actually like the country's political
parties to work together
better to solve the problems.
And look, and I agree with that.
And my approach when I was in the United
States Senate was to try to find some
issues where we could agree with the
other side on and try
to work with them on it.
And like, let me give you one example.
I'm I'm a really I really worry.
About concentration in
the corporate sector.
I worry about big corporate monopolies.
I worry that when you have only one or
two companies dominating an entire
sector, it's bad for liberty
and it's bad for prosperity.
So you may be shocked to hear this.
But I actually worked with Elizabeth
Warren on some anti monopoly stuff when I
was in the United States Senate.
But here's the problem.
The problem is there is actually a lot of
things where we could
work across the aisle.
There are a lot of Republican President
Trump was is in my view, you haven't seen
organized labor ever get behind a
Republican at least in 100 years like
they have behind Donald J.
Trump.
There are a lot of areas of common ground
common ground on that question.
The problem is as reasonable as some of
these people can be in private in public.
The current obsession of the Democratic
Party in leadership.
I'm not saying every Democrat in the
country, but the current obsession of
every Democrat in Congress is get
President Trump fight President Trump
attack President Trump.
It is impossible for us to work across
the aisle unless a person is willing to
put down their partisan sword.
Shut the hell up about fake scandals
related to Donald Trump
and actually work with us.
That's the way you make this happen.
Next.
Thank you.
I'm trying to get through as
many as many as possible, guys.
Thank you.
Good evening, Mr.
Vice President.
Hello.
I actually drove here all the
way from Memphis, Tennessee.
Go Tigers.
So I'm sure everyone here is aware of the
Memphis safe tax force that has been in
the city for about a month now.
And I checked a little
earlier as of this morning.
I believe they've
arrested 1700 people and seized.
About 300 illegal guns.
So I want to ask how does this law
enforcement objective jive with uh
Attorney General Pam Bondi's pledge to
make the Department of Justice a more pro
Second Amendment Department of Justice?
Because I'm sure most people in here
support the second Amendment.
So how can Republicans and Democrats and
this uh Department of Justice use the
current gun laws are on the books that a
lot of pro Second Amendment advocates
disagree with that we wanted to overturn
in the big beautiful
bill, but we didn't get it.
Yeah.
So I understand the question.
By the way, I supported some of those
changes in the big beautiful bill.
I know the President
United States it too.
We didn't have the votes to get him in
there and that's that's
that's a simple as that.
But I know exactly what you're talking
about because there were a couple of
issues in particular.
I talked to some of my
Second Amendment friends.
But here's the basic issue.
We don't want people who have violated
the law who have committed felonies.
The Second Amendment, like every other
amendment, it's about due process.
It's that you don't have your rights
violated unless there
is due process of law.
If you're a person who's committed four
felonies in a court has lawfully ordered
that you shouldn't have a gun and you're
running around with a firearm, I don't
have any problem with law enforcement
saying you don't get to have that firearm
that is legally
possessed, illegally obtained.
I think that's basically law and order.
Now again,
if you had, you know, if you had somebody
coming and say, well, we don't think that
person should have a firearm, but they
haven't violated any law.
That's a totally separate question.
That's not what we're focused on.
What we're focused on is violent crime
and people who have violated, you know,
the bodily autonomy of
another human people.
A person who is committed an act of
violence against one of
their fellow citizens.
We're going to clean up the streets, get
those people off the street, and make
America safe for the
American citizens again.
That is our entire law and order policy,
and I think we're doing
a pretty good job at it.
Thank you.
Thank you for the opportunity to speak.
I'm a Christian man, and I'm just
confused why that there's this notion
that we might have owe Israel something
or that they're our greatest ally or that
we have to support this.
Multi $100 billion foreign aid package to
Israel to cover this to quote Charlie
Kirk ethnic cleansing in Gaza.
I'm just confused why this idea has come
around considering the fact that not only
does their religion not agree with ours,
but also openly supports
the prosecution of ours.
Yeah, so
Let me
say things a few things about this.
First of all, when the president United
States says America first, that means
that he pursues the
interests of Americans first.
That is our entire foreign policy.
Now that doesn't mean you're not going to
have alliances that you're not going to
work with other
countries from time to time.
And that is what the president believes
is that Israel sometimes they have
similar interests in the United States
and we're going to work with them.
In that case, sometimes they don't have
similar interest in the United States.
And this example, that's the most recent
Gaza peace plan that all of us have been
working on very hard
for the past few weeks.
The president of the United States could
only get that peace deal done by actually
being willing to apply
leverage to the state of Israel.
So when people say that Israel is somehow
manipulating or controlling the president
of the United States, they're not
controlling this president of the United
States, which is one of the reasons why
would be able to have some of the success
that we've had in the Middle East.
Now you ask about, you know, sort of Jews
disagreeing with Christians
on certain religious ideas.
Yeah, absolutely.
It's one of the realities is that Jews do
not believe that Jesus
Christ is the Messiah.
Obviously Christians do believe that
there are some significant theological
disagreements between
Christians and Jews.
My attitude is let's
have those conversations.
Let's have those
disagreements when we have them.
But if there are shared areas of
interest, we ought to be
willing to do that too.
For example, I really care about one
thing I really, really care about is the
president of Israel.
I think that's an obvious
area of common interest.
I am fine with that.
What I'm not okay with is any country
coming before the interests of American
citizens, and it is important for all of
us to know that Jesus Christ is the Messiah.
Assuming we're American citizens to put
the interest of our own country first.
That's what we're gonna do.
That's what we try to
do every single day.
I promise you.
Thank you.
Hi, Mr.
Vice President.
I'm the president of our
pro life organization here.
Ole Miss Rebels for life.
Yeah.
And I myself as a
president am 100% pro life.
And I know you've stated you being
Catholic that you in the past you've
stated that you're 100% pro life.
But since joining the presidential
campaign as the VP, you've kind of
wavered how you see abortion.
So I'm just wondering what
your stance is right now.
And do you think that someone else is
right to Liberty Trump
someone else's right to life?
Well, first of all, I
appreciate your question.
And I appreciate the work that you do.
You asked the question.
Do I think somebody else's right to
Liberty Trump somebody
else's right to life?
No, no, I do not.
I, in fact, do not believe that.
Now you said I'm gonna take issue with
something you said just the premise of
the question, which is that I've wavered
on the pro life issue.
I really do believe that the president
has been the most pro life president in
the history of the
United States of America.
Now, that said, there are two things that
I think we have to keep in mind here.
Now, one is the very, very hard question
of, you know, when we talk about our
abortion policy, there are some very,
very difficult educations.
There are cases where you've got, you
know, an 11 year old girl who was raped
who it would be unsafe for
her to bring the baby to term.
You've got situations where, you know,
bringing a baby to term would cause
serious bodily harm, maybe,
maybe death for the mother.
That's one of the reasons why we believe
in the exception in this in these cases
where you have again, their edge cases.
They're rare.
I think the pro abortion community would
have you believe that's 90% of abortions.
That's not true.
We gotta be honest about the fact that
there are some edge cases.
The second thing I'd say about this is
that we have to be prudential and
practical and what can get accomplished.
And there may be
disagreements about what exactly that is.
But if you look at the pro life victories
that the president United States has been
able to achieve, he's been able to
achieve them because he is working with
the system that we have.
If your attitude is you are going to
pursue the most aggressive pro life
option, even if it means you lose every
election and every outcome means that
you're gonna be in a situation where the
Democrats have abortion on demand up to
the moment of birth to the very end.
You've got to work within the political
constraints that we have.
Now, here, let me just
say something about this.
And you know, somebody asked me earlier
about my Christian values.
And one of the points I made is that when
the settlers came to the new world, they
found a very widespread child sacrifice.
I imagine there are some people who don't
agree with my view on
on the pro life issue.
Let me just make an observation.
If you go to historical archaeological
sites where there were brothels and the
two oldest businesses in the world are
gambling and prostitution.
So there were brothels, even in very
ancient civilizations.
If you go back to ancient brothels and
you dig up the bones, of the women who
are working in these places, you will
very often find a lot of Children who
were buried with him.
And the answer is that whenever a society
decides to discard innocent babies, they
also don't treat their women very well.
And whenever a society mistreats its
women, it is very often the babies who
come right after that.
There is a reason why Christian
civilization ended the practice of child
sacrifice all over the world.
And it's one of the great accomplishments
of Christian civilization.
I believe that we should try to be
protecting every unborn life.
There's a question of
exactly how we do it.
But I would never say that anyone's life
right to life should be sacrificed.
Thank you, ma'am.
First, I just have to say I am thrilled
to hear you articulate Christian values
on a stage like this and to remind us
that we things we take for granted and
things we value so much
have a Christian origin.
So thank you for that.
I really mean that.
However, so much of liberalism, by the
way, so much of the far left is a sort of
if you really pay attention to it, it's a
kind of perverted
version of Christianity.
Like there's nothing wrong, of course,
with focusing on people who are
disenfranchised, for example, that's the
focus of liberalism.
But if you completely separate it from
any religious duty, any civic virtue,
then that can actually become, for
example, an inducement to lawlessness.
You can't just have
compassion for the criminal.
You also have to have justice to which is
why I think that a properly rooted
Christian moral order is such an
important part of the
future of our country.
But sorry, I interrupted you.
Go ahead.
No, I meant absolutely.
Now, as much as I hope and pray that we
can be a nation of Christians, the idea
of a Christian nation scares me.
So I'd like to hear your feedback on a
pretty nuanced argument here that perhaps
there should be a wall of separation as
at least one of our founders advocated
for between church and
state at the national level.
However, that line can and should get
blurrier as we descend
to the community level.
And perhaps that is actually the system,
the structure that our founders gave us
when they said Congress shall make no law
establishing a religious body.
However, states did have close
relationships with churches at that time.
Yeah.
Do you think that that
is a rationale that works?
Do you think that that is
the way we should implement?
Yes, around these Christian values.
So this is a very nuanced point.
And I want to I want to just make sure
that everybody's kind
of on the same page here.
So if you go back to the First Amendment,
it doesn't say
separation of church and state.
It says Congress shall make no law
respecting an establishment of religion.
But if you go back to the founding time,
there were actually a number of states
that had formally recognized churches.
So there was the
Anglican Church of Virginia.
That was the official
state church of Virginia.
Maryland at the time was the only
majority Catholic colony or at least had
a significant Catholic representation of
the original 13 colonies.
There's a lot there.
And yes, I do think that what happened is
the Supreme Court interpreted Congress
shall make no law respecting an
establishment of religion to effectively
throw the church out of every public
space at the federal,
state and local level.
I think it was a terrible mistake and
we're still paying for the
consequences of it today.
But if I think this is your point, if you
were to undo that, if you were to get
back to a system actually meant by the
founders where Congress is not setting up
an established religion, but people in
their local communities can kind of do
whatever it is that they want to do.
I think that would be a better system
than what we have today.
But I think the most important principle
that we have got to
remember is you do not.
You do not have to completely kick God
out of the public square, which is what
we've done in modern America.
It's not what the founders wanted.
It's not good for the
United States of America.
And anybody who tells you it's required
by the Constitution is lying to you.
Thank you.
Hello, JD.
How you doing today, man?
Good.
How you doing?
In the wise words of Ricky Bobby, I don't
know what to do with my hands.
Don't feel bad.
Neither do I half the time, man.
Okay.
First off, yeah, I'll laugh it off.
Laugh it up.
Okay.
First off, I just want to say I am a huge
supporter of the Trump administration.
I was three months too
late to vote for you guys.
But if I could have, I would have.
So I'm huge supporter of you
guys before I make my argument.
But there is something you guys are doing
that is kind of
disturbing me a little bit.
Okay, go ahead.
Thank you.
You guys, um, you guys have sent the
military into Washington, D.
C.
And a few other cities that I can't think
of off the top of my head, which first
off, they've had
wonderful results like no one.
No one can deny the results of that.
That's it's wonderful.
Some might even say the greatest.
They I'm a comedian.
I like this guy.
Who is this guy?
Thank you, JD.
Okay, right.
Let's say we get a
complete tyrant in office.
And let's say we're having, let's say,
turning point USA is having a huge
protest against, uh, you know, something
really bad that we don't like.
And let's say he's, um, a president is
saying that it's getting violent.
How can we?
What is?
what is the difference between what
you're doing and how could we how can we
prevent someone from abusing that power?
Yeah so look look I understand where the
question is coming from and I think it's
a fair question and it's going to sound
like I'm being sarcastic and it really is
is not meant in in any offense but when
you talk about what could another
administration do to take a wild
hypothetical example totally off the top
of my head what if Joe Biden sent the
federal bureau of investigation to start
arresting his political opponents?
Okay so so here's here's something that I
want conservatives I want every
conservative to remember it's an
important part of my entire political
philosophy is we cannot be afraid to do
something because the left might do it in
the future the left is already going to
do it regardless of whether we do it that
that is that is the takeaway of the last
40 years and in particular if you look at
what we're doing if Joe Biden wanted to
deploy the National Guard to a red state
in a place where the murder rate was
twice what it is in third world countries
to actually go after murderers that would
be a great use of the National Guard
unfortunately I don't think Joe Biden
would use it like that what I'm worried
about frankly is what the far left
already did with American law enforcement
and that is the thing that we have to
prevent against and the answer to that
question is you make sure the people who
did it face penalties for using the
federal power against
American citizens and by the way
that's exactly what
we're trying to do thank you
thank you Jadie honor
to meet you man good
to meet you too man
this will be the last
question Ricky Bobby 2048
that's who I'm voting for
this is the last oh wow we've been here
over an hour that's amazing okay I'm
sorry those of you didn't answer a
question I tried to be as
quick as I could go ahead Mr.
Vice President I'm humbled and honored to
be here recently President Trump endorsed
a candidate to run against Republican
representative Thomas Massey who's
opposed and criticized some of the Trump
administration's aims how would you
address those who fear that principal
disagreement or independent thinking is
to discourage within the party because of
how it can be framed as a betrayal
instead of as internal accountability or
an opportunity for debate and negotiation
so it's a very good question let me say
this one is hard for me and the reason
it's hard for me is because Thomas Massey
and I he is one of the first people that
ever reached out to me about my book or
about political office I've known Thomas
Massey well before I ever got involved in
politics Thomas's wife died a well maybe
it was a year and a half ago two years
ago it was a little while ago she died
very unexpectedly was a very sweet and
kind woman and I was probably one of the
first people that called Thomas to offer
my condolences I think the problem with
Thomas and I've told him this in private
and now I guess I'll say it in public is
it's one thing to disagree with the party
on a particular issue it's one thing to
take you know to take to have your
independent stand on a number of
questions and by the way some of the
stuff where Thomas Massey has been
independent against the Republican Party
I've agreed with him with Thomas and I
worked together during 2023 where I was
trying to stop the limitless flow of
American money to Ukraine and Thomas was
one of the people I was working closest
with it but that's one thing being
independent having your own opinions is
one thing voting against the party on
every single issue you're eventually
going to make too many enemies and that
is the problem that Thomas has had it's
not one issue it's not three or four
issues it's that every time that we've
needed Thomas for a vote he has been
completely unwilling to provide it that
is why the president of the United States
has trained his ire on Thomas Massey it's
because we can never count on him for
some of the most difficult votes I wish
that that weren't the case I say that
it's somebody who's known Thomas well
before I got into politics but politics
is politics and when you always vote
against the party you can't expect the
party to actually back up that's the
reality so but let me um let me say just
a couple of final things before I hit the
road here and and one it has been such an
amazing honor to be with all of you this
evening I want to say two things I want
to say two things number one when I was
back at my agnostic days and I was
thinking about returning to my faith I
remember talking to a friend of mine and
actually talking about you know a number
of things and he said something to me
that was really interesting and I was
talking about all the things that were
going wrong I was looking to the future I
was talking about everything that was
broken in the world and I and I said to
him I said you know things are just
really really dark and he said and he
stopped me in my tracks he said JD you're
right there are a lot of things that are
really dark out there but despair is a
sin now I know not all of you are
Christians but for the Christians out
there I think that it is very important
to remember that despair is actually a
sin it's okay to disagree it's okay to
criticize it's okay to think that things
aren't going well with a particular issue
but we are called to never give up hope
but I think one of the critical lessons
of Charlie Kirk's life to his dying
breath this was a man who never lost hope
in his creator and never lost hope in the
United States of America so let's
remember that and carry that forward as a
way to remember and the second thing that
I want to say is in line with despair
being a sin look I imagine that most I
can tell most of you apparently agree
with a lot of what I said I'm sure that a
lot of you disagree with some of the
things that I've said that's okay we
don't need in our political movement
people who agree with us on every single
issue we got a couple of questions about
Israel we got a couple of questions about
the National Guard deployments we don't
need somebody who agrees with us on every
single question or every single issue
what we need is people of good faith who
love the United States of America and are
willing to work hard to save it so when
you look at all the accomplishments you
look at the accomplishments of the last
nine months we inherited the worst border
crisis in the history of the United
States of America we shut down the border
and net immigration is two and a half
million lower today than it was in nine
months that means the total number of
people that have been sent out of this
country is two and a half million we have
two and a half million fewer illegal
immigrants than we had
that's a great accomplishment we
we inherited a terrible affordability
crisis from Joe Biden and I'm not going
to tell you everything's perfect because
it was a real bad situation that we
inherited but inflation is consistently
below economists expectations and we are
chipping away at it every single day we
inherited an economy where we had the
largest trade deficit in the history of
the United States of America in nine
months Donald Trump's tariff policies
have cut the American trade deficit by
over half that means we're making more of
our own stuff and we're actually
employing American workers to do it and
all that is to say that very often
Charlie Kirk would call me and he would
say not add a boy but he would say do
more do more do more and I listened to
Charlie because he was a dear friend and
because I knew that he loved this country
my point is the best way in your life to
honor Charlie Kirk's legacy it's not to
despair but to hope in the future of this
country if you disagree with something
then get involved in the movement to save
this country if you think that we could
be doing more than pick up the phone and
get involved in the effort to change our
minds and change the future of the United
States of America in the process my
friends the rebels of old miss despair is
a sin do not give in to despair let's
keep fighting to save the United States
of America thank you and God bless you